a corollary a parallel story to the
story of what Donald Trump is doing in
Syria is the story of corporate media's
reaction to what's going on in Syria if
you've been just sort of listening to
the show in the background up until now
this is a moment to pay close attention
okay let me give you some context from
the Iraq war people who were too young
to remember or weren't paying attention
to politics during the run-up to the
Iraq war one person posted the following
message on our reddit discussion forum I
wasn't in the US or too young anyway
between 2001 and 2003 before the war in
Iraq but what was the media like back
then I'm no fan of Assad but the way
they are talking on the cable media
channels is like urging for Trump to
invade it and as a result give a certain
group of countries more influence there
but that is my theory one thing that was
very prevalent during the run-up to the
Iraq war is that dissent was not
tolerated in corporate media the one
person in corporate media who was a
strong sceptic about going into Iraq was
MSNBC's Phil Donahue and he was kicked
off he was kicked off I had the pleasure
of meeting Phil Donahue and talked to
him personally about this and he was
removed from MSNBC because he was
questioning the move to go into Iraq the
drums of war were beating then and we
are seeing shades of that right now out
of 20 papers that published editorials
about the Trump serious strike 17 were
partially or fully in favor not not all
of these were fully in favor but at
least partially in favor with some of
the aspects of the Trump Syria strikes
look at some of these quotes that we
have here USA Today president Trump's
authorization of missile strikes
Thursday night was an appropriate way to
punish Syrian President Bashar Assad The
Wall Street Journal mr. Trump's decision
Thursday to launch a retaliatory missile
strike is an important first step to
save lives and force global order and
improve the strategic outlook for the US
and its allies the New York Times it was
hard not to feel some sense of emotional
satisfaction and justice done
when American cruise missiles struck an
airfield in Syria on Thursday the LA
Times but Trump was right when he said
it is in the vital national security
interest of the United States to prevent
and deter the spread and use of Kempe
deadly chemical weapons the New York
Post
serious strike came four years late the
New York Daily News president Trump's
decision to attack a Syrian air base
sent a meaningful message to Bashar
Assad and any other leader who considers
unleashing banned chemical weapons
against his people the chicago tribune
trump passed this first test were
relieved to report The Washington Post
Trump's decision to stride a strike a
Syrian air base in response to a
chemical weapons attack by the regime of
Bashar al-assad was right as a matter of
morality but it could also yield a host
of practical benefits and the only one
of these papers that seemed to be sort
of against it was the Houston Chronicle
which said as we said a year and a half
ago the president cannot and should not
use military force against Syria without
a legislative framework not even against
it really just saying Trump should have
gotten to do it this is dangerous
these attacks are being fetishized
almost like hey everybody's being
objective by saying aside from our views
on Trump and aside from our views on
broader military intervention in the
Middle East these strikes make at least
some sense these strikes made no sense
actually as I talked about earlier in
the show and this is starting to be
reminiscent of what we were seeing
before the Iraq invasion which as we now
know is a complete and utter disaster
and it's having an impact people are
emailing me saying David drop the anti
Trump stuff for the sake of being anti
Trump can't you see most people agree
with these strikes even if they don't
like Trump and this is how you start
manufacturing consent for this type of
thing you ignore the legality you ignore
the morality and you ignore the
practicality and it matters because we
know pat there's a Huffington Post
analysis about this that Syrian policy
has been driven by news coverage and
even this decision by Trump arguably was
because of news coverage of the the
horrible strikes by Bashar al Assad this
matters and we've got to be aware of it
people tune into the news because that's
what's sensationalist that's what drives
media attention yeah and also you have
to look at who is funding these media
outlets a lot of the times it's defense
contractors Boeing General Electric of
course whole gamut there and they have
an interest in keeping Wars going and
starting new ones very very disturbing
this is why we need alternatives to
corporate media and why we've been
crippled by the YouTube ad boycott and
that's why it's extra crucial right now
that we are actually supporting
independent media I hope you'll sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership i
hope you'll make even a dollar or two
contribution at patreon.com slash david
pakman show send me your thoughts what
are you thinking about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show wait before
you go on to the next video because of
the YouTube advertiser boycott ads
aren't playing on our YouTube channel
which means we are no longer making any
money from these videos please help us
fight back and replace the lost revenue
so that the show can stay on exactly as
it has been uninterrupted you can pledge
whatever you can even $1 per month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
need your help